yeah but also i have a long neck the way
you're built your slender your
extremities yeah
yeah freeze out yeah it freezes i i get
all hyped out i know a neighborhood
that's the only reason you're on the
supposed board
the only reason i'm not in nature is
because my neck is feeling i get it dude
if my arm would get better i'd be
playing the nfl that's exactly right the
only reason i'm starting quarterback
well well but but one of the things that
there was a guy i knew who didn't make
it in the seals because he kept hypoing
out as he said and his instructor while
they're where they're i think it was
hell week the instructor they stuck up
they stuck a thermometer up his ass and
taped it to the inside of his thigh to
make sure because he just kept [ __ ]
you know yeah how many fingers and stuff
no he just kept going out but i if you
see him he could he was his back was he
was all back he was but there was no fat
oh it doesn't matter long neck yeah
because david lives for day
yeah some guys can he's he's a taller
dude i don't know you don't know i'll
tell you guys about it
it looks like maybe six feet but yeah
he's thin he's thin he even said he said
i wasn't a good swimmer you know it was
tough for him but yeah but a lot of guys
they say a lot of guys
don't do so well because they uh because
the goal they can't handle the cold how
do you do with the cold i like to call
it he's from denver you too right hell
no i don't suck in the cold you do i
suck you're terrible i'm a dancer
they're trying to say six four that's
what i'm saying yeah david cocker [ __ ]
four [ __ ] that's right
bring up him again with standing next to
rogan uh you'll get us rogan's five
seven runs five eight
i'll give him five eight
but maybe he's five seven i don't know
standing is there a picture of them
standing oh yeah right there because
they took away right there like dave
chappelle oh wow he's definitely six
four yeah
because dave chappelle's pretty tall
horse yeah okay he's definitely tall
yeah big guy
wow stud but he yeah
yeah mr cowan all the way from uh flew
in straight from san francisco
when people say you look good when they
see you and they go you look good you
guys are getting older that's what it
means you know what it is is that what
i'm doing yeah you never said it that's
what i'm doing young people always look
good when you look at a guy and you go
you look good or when you go and you're
tired are you tired it's like oh i look
like [ __ ] that's your way of saying i
look like [ __ ] i was walking
i would say is san fran completely
normal like everything is open
everything no oh it's oh no there are a
lot of places that went completely out
of business well no i know that but i'm
saying like right now no it's it's so
that pier that we used to go to and get
all our [ __ ] awards
that's that's kind of no longer
that's now
that's not like these that's now like um
a flea market where they sell uh
imitation purses and [ __ ]
yeah
uh-huh yes san francisco that city
council has done a really good job
they're all communists
the mayor is a democrat and the city
council that makes all those rules are
literally
when you say progressive they're like
socialist communists they're so
anti-business and what happens is people
are like [ __ ] this last time i was there
was 2019 yeah and
i mean
like i know we got a crazy homeless
situation but out there
it was uh oh it's it's pretty wild oh no
it's out of the tenderloin open air drug
markets there open air drug markets uh
that where everything is basically so it
was like the wild west it was like pure
anarchy when you're up there well when i
went there i was just down in where the
old empowered gym was
so we were hanging out there yeah that's
a nice area it was like
we went to kokari that our our favorite
they had the red lamb roasting on a spin
favorite
our boy owns that restaurant yeah but
that was normal right that was normal
that was good that looked that looked
good i mean there's still san francisco
there's still people holding out with
money and stuff but it's not a good city
to bet on right now hey why not i'm
going to do cobs here soon cops you're
not going to live cops it's great
yeah right but hey man
i'm spending a week in there huh
no we're saying long-term term with
society long-term
it's just so anti-business 19 walgreens
closed down i mean some crazy amount
they just made that prop 47 where you
can steal up to a thousand dollars worth
of those merchandise just walking in
like taking like that
videos but i remember you talking about
it criminals the cartels and stuff they
were like well we'll just get we need
certain materials from under the
drugstores to make our drug whatever and
they would just have people come in
there who look kind of tough and
menacing so san fran was a [ __ ] show huh
yeah
yeah but where he lives is awesome yeah
you know 20 minutes away that's
no he doesn't live there anymore he has
an apartment there but he has oh really
i'll see you about a house all out like
in the suburbs yeah yeah
but dude it was great to see him he's
he's awesome and uh his book uh came out
on early release on amazon which is kind
of cool i can't remember what the [ __ ]
it's called but we'll talk about it when
it was a long time for you guys
yeah yeah i met him through him
tarek was like you know
now he's like he's always been an
entrepreneur but he had an amazing gym
series of gyms called in power
and uh
and just one eye chin yeah
and he also uh you sure it's out right
now it's out for early release
god it's only he did peppa pig there it
is that's him right here
yep that's it there it is baby
conquering the disease of fear by simon
schuster
um i can't wait to read it
i mean he had such a life afghan refugee
yeah you know played at fresno state d1
football how old is he um a head coach
for jake shields and those guys covered
melendez
luke rockhold for a little bit yeah all
those guys
i'll check out that i'd read a book like
that dude when we go to his [ __ ] gym
man you'd see like the booster of the
nfl
he closed he would be coveted and
everything else but he chose to close it
down i think he sold it off or something
and he's got now he now he just does
other things for various businesses oh
but there's no more empowered jim i
don't know i don't know the answer i
don't want to say yes is this the jim
newson was going to when he was trying
to facetime what's that
is that the jim newsome was that when
you was trying to facetime him or
something like that um it wasn't his gym
that was the yeah
that was his gym that's exactly right
like you'd see everybody there like the
governor [ __ ] you know the biggest
people in the nfl i mean you know she
just knows everybody all the biggest
silicon valley
you know vcs i mean they're [ __ ]
crazy people
yeah
it's just you can't not love the guy
it's just so curious see me interesting
what they do in uh california compared
to
new york right because now new york
comedy shows you have to prove
vaccination yeah like only vaccinated
people can get into restaurants and it's
really interesting time right now
because this is such a [ __ ] heat i
don't know how long it's gonna last yeah
especially modern day segregation i
heard a guy say i heard a guy say um
that he was like well okay so if if you
don't get vaccinated but then you catch
covid
and then you go to the hospital
my tax dollars have to pay for that too
so it's like it's a contentious subject
man i i don't know
it is a very i just know that all of us
are going to have to get vaccinated how
about that yeah i mean or you're just
not going to be able to participate it's
a little bit like fighting we'll see
yeah i don't know we'll see
i don't know
yeah i don't i i i don't know i think
that the stats i think the stats yeah
yeah like um people are all up in arms
what everybody should just do is just
look at the stats that the metadata if
you got three and a half billion people
that took the vaccine
where people who took the vaccine are
our deaths down where they don't are
they up apparently that's the case
people say [ __ ] that's the idea i
don't know i'll just listen every time i
hear somebody talk it's not a scientist
i'm just going to listen to scientists
how do you listen to scientists yeah i
mean why because you're actually no no
that's that'd be a different disease
control yeah like that yeah
i can find scientists to validate
whichever argument you have that's the
other thing there you go that's it what
do you do there you go well scientists
are not immune to political pressure no
yeah and the other thing that they were
talking about is that if you want to
grant if you want your grant because you
live and die by the amount of money
that's given to you from the nih
national institute of health which
voucher runs sometimes that can be like
you don't want to piss off the people
they're going to give you that'll give
you yeah
i don't know i don't know i'm done i
have no idea who knows we don't know all
i know is i'm not built for the cold and
i'm never going to be a [ __ ] navy
maybe still
i'll tell you what happens when you're
older i tell you what happens when
you're older i hate to say it
but uh
you get you can't get up from a chair
when you've been sitting down and
wrestle
just start rushing sore
little little [ __ ] little things happen
in your back and your neck even though
we were we were [ __ ] around all of a
sudden i wake up and i feel like my
neck's being held together by silly
putty and my head is in my back
everything everything's being held
together but like with pins and some
rope and like some scotch tape it's like
just everything's all rattling and like
were you sore
he's young were you sore from [ __ ]
you up oh no no no you're young
oh yeah chappelle's in here
uh christian brian wrestling i saw i saw
the video hey
you tried i did try but you did not
succeed no i did not well that man
gotcha he's never done anything he's
never done any wrestling yeah yeah uh no
never yeah how are you gonna it's not it
like i love when people are surprised
you've never done it i wasn't surprised
i know but some people are it's like
it's like playing tennis against
somebody you've never played or boxing
were you searching you know i wasn't
sore to be honest yeah i wasn't sorry
not even my arms remember you said my
arms are going to be sore because you've
been working out no zero working out by
the way who started you does not knock
out i don't know it didn't work that's
well documented i know there's a
document but i know he was like you know
a good body
i wasn't surprised i was excited that i
finally got to see you in action oh
really yeah that's why i was like i got
up all excited oh my god i got to see
him action i get it because yeah you
know stuff i wouldn't wrestle i don't
know anything about wrestling so why
would i wrestle you yeah you know well
that's why chin's always wanting to box
but he's never boxed and i worked really
hard on him so you're just going off
your pure strength no chin not straight
chin grew up fighting for his life
yeah
yeah she's a tough guy he got hit with a
damn plane it has nothing to do he's a
very tough guy i'm sure it's exactly
like with with jiu jitsu or if you've
never done that what happens is your
hands are gonna come down
for a thousand reasons you're gonna
punch in the face and that really sucks
yeah and it's not and i think boxing's
not like jiu jitsu because with jiu
jitsu like a j brennan can grab me and
[ __ ] around and like but if i start to
box with brennan he's gonna if he hits
me in the head it's a bad situation yeah
you can't kind of play it and brian you
um i'll give you this you read me when
we arm wrestled so we did it three times
i beat him the first time with the left
hand okay but then he read everything i
did the next two times he beat me both
times left hand and right now that's
what happened so that's why when you say
boxing i'm like oh [ __ ] okay exactly
yeah i would figure you out very quickly
yes
wrestling is dangerous man on the tent
you're seeing the guy blowing
i don't [ __ ] with it really yeah well
dumb dumb brian decided to throw a
football after that and this area right
here oh i'm all kinds of sore so that's
what happens when you're older football
what are you 14
arm wrestling quit flipping wrestling on
a rug wrestling here that's a problem
that attacked me i did i said let's get
a wig and just
yeah i slapped his face what i stopped
and then i got up again and then he goes
and then i could see in his face he was
like i wanna i wanna tussle uh a slap is
like that was funny though i was talking
this man shut up
damn
it's so funny good slap
there's nothing about just a
dumbest [ __ ] in the world people just
[ __ ] slapping this is so could be the
uh the tiger thick whiskey we're gonna
wiggy up just hear me out just let me
let daddy do this let that daddy do what
you made your hair like that yep getting
there
the the company reached out we're gonna
wake you up and we're gonna give you
metal braces
metal
and we're gonna fix your teeth metal
braces metal
perfect timing
oh
shut up hear me out here
hey metal braces and a wig slappy again
don't do it i don't like that [ __ ] do it
i'm going to [ __ ] you up hey
see then you got off and i knew that it
was on that that's the point of no
return you slap a person though because
sometimes i get a little too much energy
like when we were at rogan's one time we
were gonna do a podcast and i was just
like it's rough house sunday and i
started [ __ ] slapping him and i
thought i'd be okay and then
he took his watch off dude remember when
you heard that
uh pool cue how mad wrote 6000
he's like stop it because
uh brian was taking like using it as
like a [ __ ] he made him like ivory
and dinosaur bone yeah he got it from
like africa or some [ __ ] from the night
he was like crafted by those crazy
famous craftsmen and i'm sure he's like
what are you doing remember that
jesus is my life i was i was trying to
keep running away
so funny the the interesting thing about
you is that if we were in a fight and i
had a baseball bat wouldn't matter you
now it wouldn't because you take you
would absorb the blow
that's a problem i saw i saw a security
guard people have to understand in real
fight i saw a tough guy who didn't give
a [ __ ] and the security guard got mad
and security guard took out his billy
club and hit the dude
uh yeah hit the dude three times and
that guy went bat-bap-bap and just
grabbed the security i picked him up and
threw him on his [ __ ] head [ __ ] yeah
man and then the guy pulled out pepper
spray and i'd spray him but it was
missing him and it didn't help him it
did not man [ __ ] that street fighter
[ __ ]
forget it you got the chin today what
happened you had to do what are you guys
doing today i got to fight chin today
today it's going out today i thought we
were going to fight him the first day we
were back warm up a little bit
yesterday the idea is
same as you and me against brendan okay
it's just them too against me
dude i play
i bailed on you that time i was like
brian brown fed him to the whole thing's
gonna
chin is going to get pushed out
eventually but it's going to be oh my
[ __ ] god
yeah
i don't know i don't i do not know chin
is tough i just know i just know that
this [ __ ] right here is just
scrappy
that little
little christian he's a little scrappy
you know scrappy yeah you know he might
try and do some hockey move and pull
your [ __ ] shirt over your shin
it's just literally just chilling like
we should be just pushing you just want
yeah just like just like we did they
could like grab but i mean if you take
the shirt off that would be like worried
about my belly showing yeah i mean oh
damn you might need that then you might
not
brenden now i did see you reach for his
dick and squeeze so i heard people say
that no it was just weird we're just in
the moment
you never want to go low on a huge guy i
never go for single legs i just because
i thought you were gonna grab the other
one that would have made sense yeah you
[ __ ] them you [ __ ] me yeah it's okay
i learned
that was you you and i one day so after
this you two are gonna try and get
kicked out i don't know we'll see we'll
see we'll see
we'll see maybe on friday or whatever
he's nervous you're not ready friday
you're gonna be buying this korean
barbecue today
well what's the bet if you guys can get
them out korean barbecue yup yeah at
quarters yeah but there's never you know
what you know what it's like time limit
you have three minutes
yeah in fact i think you got two minutes
three minutes a little three minutes is
a lifetime dude you got two minutes or a
minute a minute sounds like a minute
yeah okay okay put it this way put it
this way so we didn't even go a minute
no that's a long time since
since chen won't do it today i'll be
your practice i'll be the practice tommy
for it all right you give me up you're
not getting chappelle out definitely not
but i'd love to try it
like your pals
but like hey i mean this is what you got
to do to get something no i'll
definitely try to the grand master over
there
probably not but it would be a good
effort we could try how do you feel
about going against your child
um he's he's too nice i think he's gonna
you know get blindsided by how nasty me
and christianity he gives you
middleweight which is fair to say
i'm really nice that's true yeah
you gotta just go low and high i want a
free meal out here so i'm ready to bring
it in
it's not like it's not going to happen
with you we can try this i wrestle big
girls every week in chappelle you're
just another big girl in my way
oh
that'll give me
yeah that's not a gun that's exactly
what you think it is
in the small of your back
grabbing the tush dog
central are you on the road this weekend
uh yeah we're at utah
wise guys no
oh you're not doing family oh that that
that
don't call family the road though you
know this sounds good yeah i know but
just be like uh no i'm out of town yeah
go out of town yeah see you pop mom and
pop getting older 81 and 80. yeah you're
my papa and mama yeah
you know i mean i love my parents yeah
but probably 10 years
if i'm lucky
i was being friendly with you right now
you know what i mean yeah papa cowan he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about cholesterol
oh you're just like i'm gonna have all
that food over there but i'm on a diet
mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah we're pretty
healthy you never know you never know
your mom's gonna live 100 she's smaller
i think so she's smaller i hope so yeah
but your dad is let me think about right
it's a big man too remember big men big
dogs he's a big dog and i you know the
other thing is his friends are dropping
like flies when you get older at 80
your friends just die man quick i think
the average eight i mean his average age
81 chin for men right yeah life
expectancy is i think seven nine um
i think it's 79. he's very healthy like
luckily like you never know dude is your
mom pretty healthy 76 brian
yeah she is his mom's tiny too so she's
going to live
76 years old 76 the average like well
he's already 82 almost
that's what i mean
so i'll say yes him as much as you can
got to see it play golf love it just
hang on that's his thing my favorite
thing to do with him go yeah i love it
just hit some golf balls and [ __ ] i got
to go to north carolina why i'm on tour
this weekend yeah oh [ __ ] i know no it's
next weekend next weekend oh next
weekend [ __ ] what am i thinking i think
you'll like it right
uh i've only been in charlotte what are
you doing in north carolina uh raleigh's
good that's great great club yeah the
raleigh improv yeah i did that good
night amazing oh you're not doing good
nights you're doing the rallying
rallying brother that's new then isn't
it uh it's not that old it's i think
it's probably like three yeah three
years old yeah because goodnight was the
place yeah
yeah
charlotte's great charlotte's good
that's the economy zone right 100 that's
great i love charlotte brian heffernan
great guy great club owner i love that
dude
um yeah man so it's this weekend you're
in utah next weekend you're back on the
road
yeah next weekend i'm in austin
i'm no i'm in houston i'm in houston
yeah at the improv august 19 2021. yeah
that's what i'm in
yeah houston improv get your tickets
everybody you know what's good for you
what have you uh oh have you watched
anything are you into any new series
ozark
very good running ozark back
i haven't seen it in so long so when you
forget how good it is yes [ __ ] it's good
at the beginning it's so intense the
beginning part oh with the cartel guy
how good is jason bateman
actor and director in that the my
favorite uh character that is the the
girl the young girl i know manchester
she's so [ __ ] good so [ __ ] god
she's good i know
i know man no i haven't seen it jackass
i see you laughing i wasn't even i don't
know right i know i i already knew the
answer come on like you've never even
heard of it i love jason
i saw reek you know reek from game but
this is a serious role i saw him for the
first time in a in a movie you can only
he can never answer reek right and and
he's playing a guy and his like i'm
thinking of myself the character is ruth
it's a small it's a small little part
and i was like that's what happens as an
actor you get this
i don't know you get typecasted you get
typecast man and that ruth is amazing
and then it's
it's
the the crazy part is like the
relationship with a bit like because
they're married and then he catches her
cheating on me he has that video of her
getting [ __ ] yes
my favorite part is uh
when you know the cartel throws her side
piece out the window and jason bateman
sees him hit the ground and they're
talking about he goes uh
he was the only thing that helps me
sleep at night at night is the sound of
your lover hitting the cement
dude i know she punches me oh my god i
know that's right
is that the thing about that that that
[ __ ] tv show is you believe it you
believe that you're just stressed out
though
it's so stressful a crime
crying and then it's also interesting
the uh
the uh the fed who's searching for him
how he's gay
oh yeah
he's like yeah that's [ __ ] right
[ __ ] the brother
and you always
you'd never see that coming it's so real
man it's so [ __ ] good now that's all
in this show yeah man yeah did you see
that
that the remake of the batman robin
um no no dc announced that robin's gay
robin's bisexual he goes on dates with
guys now
see and i knew he's gay because whenever
we bring up batman but god shows more
robin i was like oh rob might be gay if
that's your favorite character
he'll robin was awesome oh he always
said i like these batman this was more
robbing like yeah right well what's
always been assumed
he was a he was a he was a twink now i
just want to see what that i want to see
if that has an impact in viewership
because they had they had gay
superheroes
um and boys
it was clearly a game some of them know
he's all yeah no he just did the priest
his hairstyle everything i mean even the
name captain america sounded a little
gay like you know captain america with
my shield yeah and he's like put down
the beep pick up plants like you know
when i was a kid like oh he has a little
oh is that who he is a lot of sugar in
this tank dad yeah
yeah well they the the gay superheroes
that they had just didn't come off the
shelves well which one they didn't fly
off the show it's never really been one
there was they tried it out there
typing gay superheroes captain america's
theology has images or just all yeah
captain plan is very uh definitely
captain planet was the first one gay man
for first person pop-up
uh they
i don't think they've ever like really
like they tried it they tried it with
this with these comments oh these are
these are just the actors but they've
never it's never come out like like dc
announcing that robin's gay and everyone
yeah no [ __ ] yeah my question is are
kids today gonna here's why i care yeah
uh i don't know like the only good thing
is it's like kind of with like black
panther which i didn't see i don't have
no desire to see it but
like if you're a young black kid like
when you were growing up when at my age
in my [ __ ] history no blacks yeah
there's no so you couldn't relate to any
of them like it was like thor captain
america like well i'm black does that
make sense well now those young kids
have somebody to look up to like black
panther yeah so if you're a young gay
kid like not at least you have i mean
robert robin to look up to him
he sucks
basically he's like watch out batman oh
my god batman over there
he's way shorter and he's got you know
he is a twink he's a he's always been
and batman might be you know but i don't
see batman dating any girls really so
batman might be easy he does kill her
george clooney they were [ __ ] in the
movie but not in the dark knight is a
loner dude yeah might be wrestling with
some stuff you guys seen that val kilmer
duck on amazon i would never watch that
it's too depressing i know you like him
but it's also like he has throat cancer
and stuff and gets all heavy right it
gets heavy but it's it's a great story
it's like a story just like how he came
up you know like he was he was the
youngest dude uh youngest kid to uh make
it into juilliard all this stuff like he
has a very very beast he's a beast he
would just
film ever he's like he's just been
filming everything since he was a kid so
he has a lot of footage that he like
puts out there but they talk about uh
the batman he didn't like that role no
he didn't like it's weird whoever plays
batman hates that role like george
clooney regrets that's it oh really
what did you say
yeah like what you said yeah the guy
from the 60s you had nothing else to do
yeah he loved it i'm talking about now
like ben affleck [ __ ] hated it uh
what's the other guy the the guy of
christian christian bale doesn't he
didn't like it he didn't like playing it
wow really i wonder if it's part of it's
like all the actors they did you gotta
walk around this thing it's not even
that but
it'll
talk about that with superhero movies
that they almost feel like you're trying
to cop out
like like uh tom hardy said the only
reason they had venom is because his
kids were like oh we love them he's like
really he was going to turn it down like
dad do play venom he's like i'll do it
for you guys but he hated doing it oh
really hmm
i believe it man that's something that's
like hated playing daredevil they just
but you're also shooting most of it in a
in a
giant like green screen
you're an actor shut up
am i going to pay me for it always come
on the greens wait he didn't let
all right so anyway
so when you're playing a superhero and
you're playing in front of a green
screen you don't have anybody to play i
feel so bad for them
it's like
it's like you paid millions of dollars
and then you all day in front of a green
screen would you want to do that
yeah dude i would [ __ ] put face paint
on me
and [ __ ] put me in a bat suit dude
and i'm on all these steroids and i look
jacked as [ __ ]
i don't know why i think it's so funny
shut up
shut up slap
in the middle of my sentence
when i got done with game of thrones i'm
so sad it was over i watched the behind
the scenes they have like a whole
documentary most of that's on green
screen too [ __ ]
jon snow is exactly five feet tall or
something crazy he's a little dude
but they mention it in the show they
always talk about his height even the
show they addressed it oh like little
man powerful guy but you know
i guess apparently on the last season he
like went through crazy depression he
was like suicidal he's not five but
that's okay yeah oh my boy got got
um ned stark man
oh yeah you're on season one yeah joel
just finished why did he get to his
house
uh i don't just cuz i i don't know i you
know i mean i just as an actor i would
watch that and i was like oof i mean
well think about their they're in
costumes they're in belfast they're
shooting at night they had like i think
19 weeks in a row where they shot just
that night when they're shooting like
the battle of the bastards and you have
no lie you have one line and you have to
be in the back well not him but you have
the extras also but even when you're a
star
you're in the background you're on a
horse and you're waiting and you're
there i'm telling you for 15 hours
because you had what you said is we must
move forward even if you're a star
that's your line that day and then
that's what you do that day 15 hours
yeah dude i'm telling you you said it's
like a page a day so nick you guys might
be a little young with nick nolte hall
of famer like nick nolte is a guy
okay yeah
he's been canceled if they made first 48
in today's world correct eddie murphy
the n-word yeah full-time yeah and i i
but he was amazing and i and i'm doing
warrior with him and we're in there he
there he is a guy i grew up watching you
know i'm finally an actor and i've i got
lines in this movie and we're in this
group and we're we're um
the scene is basically
we are in the background standing there
while the other characters like are
being announced for the fight yeah
and i look at him and i go
we're extras today you're nick nolte and
you're an actor and he goes that's the
name of the game that's that's that's
the job and i went but you're we're just
gonna sit here in this group and pretend
to be talking every time that camera
comes by and we're gonna do that
for
we did it for i don't know 11 12 13
hours and that was when my mother was
watching me that day and she she looked
at me and she goes you don't like acting
yes i do sorry about that part though
yeah
but that is a lot of what it is
do you want to see it great nine to five
did you see him when he plays when he's
drunk with with his son and you see what
why his son hates him oh my god what
movie
in warrior he won an oscar he was
nominated for an oscar for it and you
know i know how much he made not a lot
of not a lot for that
not a lot
very little
oh i don't know
um you got paid millions though you
weren't working for a day that
particular movie was when they started
stopped paying actors as much because
they didn't need to but we still made
more than anybody makes it a lot of
money he makes more money
so shut your [ __ ] mouth and also the
extras on game of thrones in the back
you know how much money they made
perhaps so towards season 6 the actors
no i'm saying like kit like the main guy
or whatever
i mean bring up their salaries it was
nuts
but here's the thing like the the crew
was cry at the end when they wrapped you
i realized that those ten years of their
life yeah ten years and they're flying
out there every single day that is they
were awesome
yeah i think it said they become your
family except for one person for one
person's family dude
they're married now
they are oh hell yeah uh not those two
uh he he married you know one that goes
you know nothing jon snow he may that's
his real wife now let me see
which one so this is emilia amelia
whatever clark clark and kate harrington
made 500 000 per episode jesus christ
so grab me a [ __ ] river get on that
horse
say you're one line and shut the [ __ ] up
i would do that for that yeah of course
you were 500 500
per episode
1.2 million some people made 1.2 yeah
like the main cast made up over a
million episodes you know nothing jon
snow who who was that she was you
remember she was uh she was a uh uh
wildling she was like one of the main
ones oh she was sick
yeah i remember they got married to her
they're married they have kiddos i think
they have kiddos and men have made that
up
yeah yeah that she was very sexy she's
cool yeah
yeah she was a redhead kind of right
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're married
together
like when you watch that behind the
scenes yeah ten years
ten years same thing but that's why they
said like the writer i was talking to my
boy about it who's involved with it he
goes you gotta realize like
hbo wanted to go five more seasons like
we literally we can't man it's like
60 hour work weeks for the past 10 years
we're exhausted you don't have a lot
like they didn't want to keep doing it
like we we literally can't keep doing we
because you you cannot i feel like
there's so much more they could have
done but when you hear them like we
can't like we're [ __ ] done dude well
there's so much to that you're shooting
in the middle of they have to set up
encampments you're shooting in the
middle of like i don't know it's like
like like iceland or something they had
a few and i said there's croatia they're
crochet belfast yeah but you are there
16 hours a day and you will not have a
life you can't have a relationship you
can't do it
hey working nine to five
i'm just working nine to five i like
kelly i'm just go get a job hi sir yeah
sir
i'm sir
i like the
i like the the what the head white
walker the the night king yeah i mean he
doesn't talk no he doesn't he just puts
on the makeup yep and they show him uh
like you know when they're walking
through spain the fans are you know it's
the height you know it's the most
watched show ever correct i did not know
that ever ever the biggest show of all
time wow so when they went to spain
there's like people outside their hotel
like when [ __ ] uh
jon snow was there like they're going
nuts for him and then the white walker
comes out and he's like
and no one's cheering me goes come on
and then i'll know he's like it's night
king
yeah but dude he's like i know i see
online people like oh anybody could play
the night king you know i know i don't
have speaking roles but yeah yeah
that's exactly i told my girl i could
bet nike yeah she was regular oh yeah
now as a guy who has put that makeup on
basically i've i've worn that makeup
sir
sir i'm gonna add
sir
sir please it's 600 dude first of all
it's you wanna be after three four hours
six hours of makeup yeah and then you
have one line and you gotta sit in the
background and get paid millions of
dollars now hold on sir if you think you
want to be an actor think again sir then
you have to take it off and it's hell on
your skin yeah
did you get nine to five dude how many
how many episodes was he actually in
though
a bunch yeah
well not the first five seasons well
like season six he's in a bunch he's
basically step up and then the camera
zooms in on you and you stand there like
that and you look off he has no speaking
right he doesn't talk the entire time
click that great [ __ ] character
though yeah this one are you talking
about the drop down no that that usually
tells on those
that documentary zooms in on one of the
extras where was his lifelong dream to
be an actor and then he was in all six
seasons and he played like you know he's
part of like the the [ __ ] soldiers
yeah and he's so into it man but
just his passion for it oh my dude god
bless and they get coats at the end of
every season so he has like a you know a
stark coat and a guy would come by and
like another like a baldwin coat and
he'd like what the [ __ ] is it get out of
here really just so into it sometimes
though you need like you need those
people enthusiastic uh uh yeah you want
actors as extras because a lot of times
if they have to be screaming or
bad you know whatever they're doing
some of them phone it in they're just
bad they're just going yeah
and the director will be like guys i
don't believe you you got to make it
more you know so they try to get actors
in there you try to get people that want
to be active
they want to be they're going to be want
to be well this guy it was like their
life it was his lifelong dream to be
game of thrones a lot of times though
it's so funny because that's always one
in a group where it goes over the top
there's the camera let's do this
he's looking at the camera
hey
look at the camera okay look at the
camera there he's like oh damn it yeah
you can't look at the camera
yeah
but yeah ten years of your [ __ ] life
ten years man 60 hour work weeks for
like the writers and [ __ ] beast i was
doing that when i did hangover 2 i
remember
that at the time it was the biggest
sequel and there was a muay thai fighter
this this guy from like albania and he
was a good [ __ ] dude and he was just
so happy to be there he's playing like a
an fbi guy or whatever
and i remember i
i said uh something like i think when
they grab me they should grab me but i
need somebody strong and i think i had
him grab me so he was going to be in the
shot you know
and he called his mother i heard him
call his mom and made me want to cry he
was so excited he was talking to his
mother and he cut that part out and he
said
my no my mother is crying because i told
her i'm gonna be in this shot with you
and it's like yeah i think he's gonna be
like the next [ __ ] tom cruise yeah
it's [ __ ] hangover too you're gonna
see him and she was crying and it was
just for me it was like well it makes
sense if there's got a strong guy you
know because i'm going to try to you
know
oh it's [ __ ] unbelievable it's nice
of you brian i'm a great guy dude yeah
somewhere in albany mania there's a
woman who's very thankful
for my i hope you still talk to the guy
yeah i do
he was uh he was there to compete muay
thai didn't work out
i'm trying to think about what other
shows have been as long as [ __ ] game
of thrones because when they film it
it's a beast oh yeah one of the shows
have been out as far as
long order
you're not makeup and you're not in
belfast and iceland and spain like it's
also wall normally
you're also filming at all hours of the
night in the freezing cold
dude i did that one criminal mind is
better yeah [ __ ] that i don't [ __ ] with
any of it when they brought back uh
christopher maloney's so underrated in
that show oh he's the best i i'm friends
with chris
doesn't count what else though
i did everything i mean i didn't know
what i was trying to think of shows like
game of thrones like that that like
you're like basically family
like seinfeld was only six seasons right
that's like new york time
like that's a sitcom that's a blast yeah
yeah you come in you're doing a play
you're not working the way those guys
are with you you live at home you go
home you have a nine to five basically
you know why i see damn every sunday
when i take my son to that car show in
malibu is spike i forget his last name
spike something but he was a writer on
he's best friends with jerry seinfeld
okay they own a car club and he has a
car podcast make some real money oh i
mean he has all the money yeah but him
and jerry are best friends but he brings
his cars there and yeah man well that's
that's it's always similar greatest game
in the world because what happens is if
you're an actor because i did fraser i
did you know all those shows that's him
there you show up you just show up man
and and
in the so on a monday you'll be you'll
get there at 10
and then you'll have a table read and
then they'll put it on his feet sort of
gently but you know the script's going
to change and you're going to have notes
and then you're kind of out of there by
three
that's a monday and then tuesday you're
gonna do a camera block probably be out
of there by four ten to four and then
like you know when and the only day that
you the last day friday when you
actually shoot that's when you'll be
there you'll get there at probably
11
for a camera block a run through and
then then you have the show that night
yeah but it's a blast it's everything is
a blast so are you like 50 50 with
acting because sometimes you like it
sometimes you don't i don't like it you
don't like it no i haven't you've had
your phone i had a [ __ ] blast on the
goldbergs and i had a blast on school
yeah but you can ask him i was there for
a long period of time like making this
podcast was a [ __ ] it would
drive him crazy yeah because i used to
have to negotiate i have to run from the
set i come in my shorts sometimes yeah
and makeup and i do the podcast and have
to run back and stuff it just finishes
yeah yeah
but but i mean i yeah i love that
because i love the people i was working
with yeah and i that's what i can't
think of any other shows like game of
thrones that were that much like energy
oh you mean uh like time energy the
production
the value of it the thing about game of
thrones was was two things one is the
costumes and two is the [ __ ]
locations and you oh you know what the
the the writers told me the worst part
was the horses oh i'm sure they said
they never they said if they ever take
another job again we'll never be with
horses oh [ __ ] sammy horses are in game
dangerous because you have to have horse
handlers like when they were doing like
water for chocolate yeah my buddy's a
stunt man uh i had to go do a
a stunt where i had to rear up on a
horse and my buddy's stunt man goes
you're not gonna rear on the horse and i
go why he goes because the horse is
driving you riding you i go no i know
how to ride a horse and he goes yeah i
know the problem is that horse is roll
trained he goes and he see how he's
favoring his right hand this way you
have a stunt man he goes you see how
he's favoring with his right hand and i
go um
and the guy goes yeah and he goes so if
he rears up he's going to pull this way
naturally right and then the horse is
going to roll is that a possibility and
the guy goes that is a possibility he
goes yeah get off the horse we'll get
our horses you know that horse falling
oh thank god that's why that stunt man
said i'll drive with you 60 miles away
and came with me he came with me and i
can ride a horse so i'm doing a figure
eight i'm doing whatever he tells me he
goes all right exactly
i grew up riding but i don't know how to
ride a horse
i didn't grow up riding that's a lot you
did though but i did ride you rode yeah
yeah daddy grew up rich not rich very
rich
stupid rich no he's not rich
but daddy was a banker daddy was a
banker yeah so he had some you know so i
was able to take horse lessons or
sprague lessons in greece
but i was living in
my favorite slave i mean jesus christ
that's all i'm saying
yeah it was so funny though because
i'm going to rear up on a horse and he's
just like it was so funny he goes he
goes he goes like this he goes what are
you doing i got a rear up on a horse so
i got to drive out and he goes where and
i go bubba bunny goes yeah i know that
ranch i said i said do you ride horses i
said yeah i rode horses when i was a kid
he goes when you were a kid yeah and i
wrote and i wrote in malibu my girl you
stride so i went to mill creek and road
he goes uh-huh he is and you have to
rear up like hey i'll come with you i go
60 miles away
it's okay he goes it's okay i'll come
with you one of our friends karen karen
yeah he's a good dude and a great dad
and he and he comes out and he it was so
funny he comes out not saying a word
drives all the way out there this is
what a friend does for you an old actor
bry is doing he goes do it figure eight
then turn the other way so i i might put
weight here on this this the leg pull
this way
inside but i'm inside it's really cushy
i'm in an inside area i'm not outside
i'm an inside little pen yeah and he
goes are you ready to rear up yup no
he's not going to do that no because if
you do the horde yeah i'm going to pull
yeah
but there was a point
oh yeah oh oh you grew up even better no
no even better even better he says um he
says oh i know that guy i said what do
you mean he goes that guy got trampled
and almost killed
on on because i worked on i think was
water for chocolate or whatever and i
said chocolate for elephants is that
right that's what it was no water for
elephants thank you dude i think
waterfront great movie i didn't see it
chocolate relevance is a dope title but
i think trunkle kills the water for
chocolate no there's there's water
there's water water there's water for
elephants chocolate for elephants sounds
lit as [ __ ] too
chocolate can the elephants eat
chocolate chips
no they can't though could it caffeine
water for chocolate like water for
chocolate like water for chocolate okay
there's water for elephants what if
eleven is the big movie that was like
2011 yeah a lot of horses circus so so
uh pat or uh the guy from uh twilight's
in it so karen looks at the guy and
karen goes karen goes oh i worked that
guy and he got [ __ ] he almost got
killed by a bunch of horses what
happened was
the guy was going to let the horses out
somehow the horses got spooked now
horses are hurt animals and they all ran
out together and bang that you know like
big metal gates knocked him down and
they all ran over him
and i and he said he got that guy
he goes i don't think that guy knows
horses well and i don't trust him that's
why he said he said that yes dude he
said go on i was like this i go we like
what and the horse was like you're like
no
no and then you don't set the guy he
goes you guys you worked on water for
elephants
yeah and he goes yeah me too you got
trampled by all those horses right he
goes i did you guys yeah i remember you
got pretty [ __ ] up because yeah i was
in hospital for a while i was like holy
[ __ ] damn horses terrifying me i ain't
trying to ride them bro no they're
terrifying i mean
you're like on game of thrones point
being nightmare you got to have a hand
when they show them because you know on
the horses they when they like get fake
stabbed and fall too there was the the
riders fall with the horses and like
stop do a special stuntman dude
you gotta have real horse dudes there
[ __ ] that you met the remember i went to
the all-white horse farm in kentucky i
wasn't with you in kentucky
just white horses it's called kkk yeah
yeah he definitely raided the capitol
but um on white horses just all white
horses wow that's cool i wonder why a
white horse were there a type of horse
because there's a lip singer horses no
the ones that rear up he only allowed
white horses huh huh yeah in kentucky
and kentucky interesting doesn't
surprise me
and you support that
yeah he was
there up on their nose yeah justin was
so scared of it they're just lip-syncing
i'm terrified of horses
they're big white horses oh no that's
lip singer the lip singer is uh
so you know the types of horses brian
have you ever ridden a horse chapelle or
not [ __ ] no i ain't right no damn [ __ ]
really i rhyme in montana i'm going i'm
going first week in september i'm not
riding normally i'll ride the [ __ ] out
of them dude nice i put them to work
y'all ride horses let's take it i did
before him and herman's got the [ __ ] out
to wally they do have some wine [ __ ]
have a
meal what
yeah you don't have a meal where wally's
the [ __ ] wally's oh you don't know
wally's oh dude wine and great food i
can't believe you don't know what's in a
drink brian beverly hills in santa
monica you love it
he doesn't drink yeah i don't drink all
right so tell y'all you're gonna take me
to a while wait why are we taking two
podcasts
and when you take two black guys
herman has a herman rice has a wine now
a podcast yeah there's a wine podcast oh
i bet that's exciting yeah
oh that's wally's there you'd love
wall-e oh that food looks amazing how
the food looks
[ __ ] crazy dude you love wall-e's man
right up here i'm going to scope it
tomorrow there you go that's
that's good though
[ __ ] a cheese board but that does that
steak look dope oh man come on yeah i
was drinking a lot of wine
don't say that what's that green [ __ ] to
the right of it those are fava beans
probably
and
or
that's
like some kind of a mousse spinach
mousse or some [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] so
good hard pass on that knock that off oh
you'd like that steak looks nice you
know what those are chapelle for ten
temperatures i don't know what that is
okay go back go back tell me these
little truffles that's shaved mushrooms
my favorite restaurant is shake shack
dog have you ever
had a shake uh have you ever or we've
had remember that black truffle oh yeah
i love me some truffle you're damn right
a little truffle pig
i'm a little truffle you know what you
know i just realizing a little truffle
you have trouble i love truffles yeah
you are the it's like a distinct tape
now you're talking about anything you
put on it you're talking about white
truffles now
now you're talking my wife truffles
now you're talking about i'm a little
white truffle
mushrooms right there that would be
about ten thousand dollars i heard i
heard i heard i just recently
like the big ones when they shave those
on you they shave a couple on your pasta
that's a hundred dollar pasta dish
now ask brennan though the white truffle
that's got it's got something to say and
it and the reason you pay for that is it
tastes like nothing else
it's a distinct flavor they make it an
oil
yeah right they live they live those
truffles can be as deep as six feet
under the ground so you gotta know you
gotta use a real good pig you need a
real good nose a little trouble yeah
piggy yeah that's what i realized i love
truffle
truffles
they mix it with a lot of stuff yeah
huh like like trouble like oil pastas
look at those pizzas you can get truffle
oil on if you order like a poke bowl oh
okay
yeah it's it's it's a very very strong
smell yeah it'll overpower anything and
they got some noses i love me a little
truffle pig yup they're expensive
little truffles i'll get one as a mascot
for the new thing i don't i think you
can probably use a pot belly one of
those vietnamese pot belly pigs those
are stupid well they'll just lie around
get a teacup pig for the i think i know
it's going to [ __ ] everywhere though can
can you leave them on their own though
can they just do it tiny wait um teacup
pig yeah you're going to kyle you got a
new place will you take care of the tea
cup pig i'll watch it for sure all right
that might be a thing you could keep
here because they're just like whatever
but there's a new place and there's a
yard and [ __ ] oh
let's leave it at your place dude you're
bringing her monday
i i submit that you'd get so bored of a
[ __ ] pig oh dude doesn't it just stay
that size
compared to a cat holy [ __ ] they're cute
they are really cute what do they eat
carrots and [ __ ] they are adorable they
get big they get bigger
oh look at that one and some of them
will give you a good tuscan look at that
thick [ __ ] some of them are mean
yeah yeah they'll give you a good idea
we're not going to raise them be mean
well even if you don't raise them i know
if uh my friend back home has a pig and
he bites
everybody like farm pig
raising the house now if you want to get
rid of a body if you want to get rid of
a body you get a hog farm and you keep
them hungry you keep the ribs on them
you go you keep them super hungry like
the movie hannibal that's right or the
or that's that's serious zero zero zero
yep where piggies eat everything oh yeah
they eat bacon too come right to your
face what they they eat like they'll eat
bacon too hell yeah
yeah they'll eat it all dude dude
cannibalism we're gonna get one of those
teacup pigs we're gonna name them bacon
and you're gonna take care of all right
that's fine you gotta name a pig
something ironic like it's porkchop my
friend had a turtle named fury it's
[ __ ] hilarious that's funny that's a
good name crispy baby gotta be you know
or or you get that i saw that video
i think a good name for a pig is crispy
they already have that
they do but yeah the crispy bacon
remember that news reporter he couldn't
stop laughing i said that's why i like
that
he's good
like slim slime's good like pork chop
slim's funny slime's good pork chop
slim speedy
ham fat ass yep skinny fat piece of [ __ ]
all right i knew somebody had a pitbull
and they named it cow that's hilarious
so that's actually really funny i love
that cow come here
that's pretty funny
i like a sense of humor you sipping on
that tiger thick no this is a different
one some other japanese whiskey they
sent it's pretty nice though yeah so
it's doing that and you know it's trying
to mix up middle of the day i hate been
drinking at all let's start drinking
again to miss it sometimes wine or
whiskey nothing i thought you said
you're going to start drinking again
no i'm having you haven't been making
start
yeah
yeah life's too short not too bad
i mean you're real [ __ ] boy a couple of
drinks what i'm trying to do you don't
get drunk though no i've never seen
brian i don't think we've ever been
drunk
i've never seen you drunk you drunk i
don't get drunk yeah
we we've i mean in austin we might have
drank we were just hot is that what it
was
cause we were laughing so far first of
all we smoked weed and then we also did
dmt well dmt was the greatest thing of
all time that's right that was the
greatest thing in all time what the do
you think it was the greatest thing of
all time i thought it was such a
exaggeration a little bit well i just
thought it was really cool it made me
real emotional i remember that i started
crying i do but but not when we did it
the next one we did grant and i wanted
to keep doing it how long is the trip
it feels like seven days but i asked i
asked my boy aubry like how long was
that he's like that was like 30 seconds
so you have to have someone watching you
when you do it not really i can't really
understand because once you figure out
audrey's basically a shaman yeah
i meant yeah well cause brent and i
didn't know what to expect and we got
there and we his assistant said
something like so bro aubry will
probably bring you through the ceremony
later on today and now brent and i are
not seasoned drug
ceremony we sure as [ __ ] ain't ain't
psychedelic guys we don't know so i'm
never touched we're both we're but we're
also both kind of macho so we both go
we're both like ceremony
i think i did i think i yelled out gay
yeah and she goes and she just went
you'll see and we were like well i don't
know if you know and and then he gets
there and we get in the office and he's
ceremony he does a prayer nice yeah
there's a whole incentive there's like
incense it was all dark there was a rain
stick if i recall it was a rain stick
there's a big dick there was a pig there
was a big that was dark dick and stuff
doesn't wait i thought this was a rain
stick i don't know and then we were in
panties i can't remember what happened
you keep tugging us some rain all right
i was like wait what yeah and we were
like all right i smoked it that's right
yeah i do yeah it was a good time yeah
but the next time that ayahuasca stuff
no never i would never go that that's
the one that's like makes you puke in
like well that's what it is though it's
ayahuasca the version of that it's the
hardest condensed wait dmt is yeah i
took it off into outer space and i was
like an all gold like yeah i'll do it
but you didn't feel sick from that no i
feel like no matter what i watched but
i did get real emotional the next day i
started crying because our friend tim
kennedy when i say crying brian's on the
phone and i i can't stop crying i was
talking to my wife at the time i'm like
i literally [ __ ]
dude snot bubbles he's got something i
don't know
i don't know out of nowhere i have
ray-bans
no we've done a podcast and you said you
didn't i don't want you i don't want tim
to die he's going to go off and i was
like i don't i don't want him to die
either and he goes but he's going to go
off in the field and i go yeah i know
he's going to go out there and then he's
like i know but i don't want him to die
and i go
i don't either
he just kept saying he's going to have a
party and then they went up partying his
house huge
party which was basically a snoop doggy
dog video yeah it was fantastic so we're
going there and and and i get a call and
i'm literally like his wife and i'm like
i'm like hey babe what's up i'm staring
out the window gazing out the window
okay yeah all of a sudden i just see
i see him going he's got sunglasses he's
like
uncontrollably funny i literally go like
this he goes babe hold on go i go i got
a weeping giant next to me and i gotta
go and i'm just gonna stop crying yeah
and i go now are these allergies or are
you just [ __ ]
crying i'm talking full blown snot all
you can say
dude you were like dude how long was
this trip
or the trip the trip that uh
we're in austin for three days when you
do that [ __ ] you never know what's going
to happen you never know that that's
what that came out like i just couldn't
stop crying i'll be honest i'll tell you
a story you know me i'm not very
emotional but i went that tough year
yeah
yeah but but um i was told that emotions
were weak my whole life so i always kept
it to myself yeah terrible parenting
whatever you call it sure my dad had the
same problem yep and my mom yeah um all
kinds of stuff and so uh huh and i
uh my my friend i'm at dinner at scopa
and uh my friend's girlfriend i don't
know
starts telling me a story about her
childhood and and she told it
that with about as much emotion as you
would tell somebody how you if you were
describing your horse story no it was it
was about as much emotion as you'd use
if you were telling somebody about an
errand you ran that day sure okay i went
i got on the bus and then i i went and
got a loaf of bread and i got back on
the bus and came home
that like that and she started telling
me about her childhood
which was so
so tough because her mom was crazy and
all that and i could tell that
everything she was saying was true you
don't think she was live [ __ ] no
remind me i just went like this and in
the middle of dinner
in front of this person i don't know and
to another couple i started to [ __ ] i
go i'm going to start crying here and i
started [ __ ] crying wow and i
couldn't stop crying it's been a
powerful story the only other time that
happened was when artie lang told me
about his dad and how his dad died yeah
and i'm [ __ ] i just started a crying
man i could because sometimes when
somebody tells you a story and there's
no emotional there's no emotion that you
have to take it all on [ __ ]
was that the last time you cried yes
that was the last time i cried damn no
that's not true when was that
it was pretty recent how recent
i don't what were you gonna say i cried
i've seen you cry when our friend got
when we thought our friend was gonna
commit suicide
you and i both started crying
um
we're in santa monica getting coffee we
both started crying
yeah because i said i don't know how to
help him remember um so this girl you
this girl that went on rogan so many
people are like dude yeah listen this
girl's story on north korea how kids
were you dying i know her she escaped
better apparently she's
now hold on before i say the story
i don't know anything about this woman i
didn't listen to the podcast i've seen
all the headlines all that stuff
apparently from other friends that i
have go she's kind of like she wants to
be like the kim kardashian of north
korea like she's just doing it for
exposure she's made all of this up
because i i
talk with her and i have her number in
my phone
cause i was gonna go do a thing in new
york sure apparently she's full of [ __ ]
and i also had seen her see and this is
tim dillon our good friend of mine goes
i heard this trick who's making the
pockets rounds as a fraud and she was
the kim kardashian of north korea korea
he was like continue to support now does
he know that because that's a hard thing
to say hold on bubba it's
damn it one thing about tim i don't
think he would have a
that's one thing tim's not
great comic
fantastic friend not a bullshitter yeah
i i i have i will keep my opinion to
myself because i had i had an
interesting
feeling when i was speaking to this
person for the hour that i spent spoke
to her by interesting feeling do you
mean calling [ __ ] and you know
[ __ ] or brian yeah again i don't i
know nothing about this woman i didn't
see the podcast so i don't know but i
saw this and i was like because so many
people like dude everyone was ready
they're like you should hear a story
yeah how bad north korea is and stuff
like that like jesus is a crazy story i
don't know man her story was very
powerful when i listened to it on ted on
a ted talk so um
she's been around for a minute but i
have i had without going into details
there were things about her that i found
to be
uh
interesting
interesting
yeah it's interesting right so what do
anybody's in here has heard of this you
you never heard of you've never heard of
it i just saw her popping up on youtube
a lot all over yeah yeah
and then and then i read something on
barstool who's like yeah i hear this
crazy story so i clicked on the i
clicked on the clip and it was
so tragic i was like i don't want it
yeah they're like yo this whole podcast
i'm like i'm all set right i got it
right i'm all set right and i saw it
popping up other places and then i was
talking to a good buddy about he's like
yeah dude have you seen i apparently
she's a fraud she makes a lot of this up
i'm like no way
and then i saw then someone sent me that
i was like yeah even tim dillon's
calling it i'm like oh [ __ ]
again i don't know it could be all true
how i'm not trying to start a rumor no i
don't know but i'm just saying it's well
um somebody else in here knew
interesting because when when [ __ ] like
this happens
uh
okay
when [ __ ] like this happens it's it's
interesting because there's a lot a lot
of times there probably is some truth to
it scroll down absolutely not she's been
caught lying about so many things that
everything she says is suspect
journalists have lost their careers for
lies she's making more money saying
shocking things than experts and even
though the factors are on it's uh it's
really claimed to cross the gobi desert
in four degrees low weather without any
winter clothing and justify the claims
outrageous by appealing to miracles huh
i don't know man i i maybe maybe this is
a north korean
uh
psyop to discredit that's what they do
that is what they do so that could also
be the case so we have to be careful i i
when i heard her story and and i i found
it very credible
um and it's it's and if it's not true i
guarantee that that story happens all
the time in north korea when you try to
get out of there you know so maybe
it's a horrible place maybe no no north
korea is the worst place
yeah awful so i think that story exists
whether or not it happens
i i i don't know uh here's what i don't
know here's what i'll say i literally i
don't know i just i don't know i thought
this was interesting to talk about i i
don't i can't i couldn't tell your name
all i know is i've had a bunch of people
that i know and trust go dude i think
she might be fully so here's what i'm
going to say i guess i can say this i'm
going to slap your face you can trap
things up dude tell the horror story if
i'm here where are you going to go right
yeah
i'm going to slap you and your lying
friend i'm going to slap you back okay
you don't know who's fully if she's a
liar yet no i have no idea i i
but i'm a betting man
yeah if i have to bet well it's just you
know i don't know
when dylan tweets it out
and i know he probably does his he does
his [ __ ] deep dives and [ __ ] like
that's what he does you know that's just
what he does but he's a kid and i don't
think he would put it out there
but also i don't think he'd put
something out there has he tweeted any
more about it
is it a north korean psyop they're they
have they have their own [ __ ] oh yeah
they got to infiltrate the media and
stuff like that does she does she live
in the states now or something yeah yeah
i can see the north koreans doing this
to her
so before i say anything i don't want to
i don't want to condemn her yeah yeah i
don't know enough about it yeah
yeah
did tim hear this from a reliable source
because tim's pretty fair what was it
oh there it is
okay so i'm just going to say this i'm
going to say this click on that uh say
but i'll click
the way she's dressed is very considered
and theatrical okay this one i saw too
that says 2014
yeah the way she's from 2014 2014 is
deliberate and considered
like there is the thing keep scrolling
down
celebrity defector
park is one of the stars of a television
program featuring cast of north korean
women it's called now on my way to meet
you
uh
okay
like here's the thing
she's known as the paris hilton north
korea
in one episode early in 2013 she appears
with her mother family photographers
flash on screen parks jokes that's my
mom there she's beautiful right
to be honest i'm not piercing my mom is
the real piercing okay
yeah oh do you guys know this website or
although i don't know
i read a lot of this it was called the
diplomat yeah yeah i don't know it's
from 2014 so i don't know either yeah
yeah i don't know who knows it's
interesting to talk about now yeah
um
in a way i don't mind that she's
bringing she's highlighting it she's
highlighting what a [ __ ] horrible
regime it is and i don't mind that like
and if she did come from north korea if
that's true
that in a way i guarantee things weren't
easy no right but she crossed that
arctic desert with no clothes on that's
a question how did she get spun up the
lies a little yeah how did she get
across though did she lose her sister
yeah did her father was her father in a
work camp
that's all possible yeah you know um but
she
is very she is very beautiful she's very
beautiful
i believe she's had
stuff going on yeah that would be common
common in that culture right yeah south
korea for sure
very very she's pretty yeah very doll
like you know kind of
there was yeah
i thought that was interesting i was
like
you know
but i don't know
english is great
she's she's
she seemed very kind
very kind
so i don't know yeah i never heard about
her until uh everyone kept posting from
her being on rogan yeah i think we're
going to find out yeah but the question
oh yeah we'll dive into it yeah but the
question is does it matter right if she
came from north korea i think it does we
don't well if she came from north korea
we
we don't know how do we find out that
she you know yeah if her dad was in a
work camp which he probably wasn't and
died of cancer if her sister was killed
by a border guard you know i don't
really care to be honest yeah like she
lies or not it's not the end of the
world that she's
yeah it's not the end of the world she
might have added a little spice to her
story
it is interesting if you came from north
korea already i'm going to go through
your life sucks because she's really
small too and like my friend my friend
was doing security for the olympics he
said i'm not afraid of the north koreans
anymore i said why he goes they're so
tiny their their lack of nutrition is so
crazy even among their best athletes
that they're tiny they look tiny so
she's tiny she's like so tinder a rarity
koreans are you'll see some thick
strongest buck koreans i was actually
born in korea though so i am more rare i
would say yeah yeah i knew [ __ ] are you
your folks are tall yeah
thick though oh they're not brands are
thick yeah here there's a bunch of huge
greens like i have two friends that are
here they're not right in korea they're
not naturally i was the biggest one when
i visited korea but they're always the
creators are pretty thick actually yeah
don't you think yeah i mean i had i was
like before there's judo they're really
powerless yeah
no they kick gas yeah
see how many goals they want
powerlifting
i don't think oh no it's china that
kicks ass
especially in wrestling wrestling
wrestling wrestling yeah it back judo
and power lifting and olympic lifting
please two gold medals there you go
greco-roman wrestling that's it's pretty
good
quan ho sin
was that this let's see well two on
twelve a little bit
all right it's china with the power
yeah trying to hold on good just go up
to overall uh medals chin for me out of
uh countries
2021 olympic medal gold medals yeah
america dominated did they yeah we
dominated right then china second we
dominated wow
i did not you didn't i didn't actually
um china 38. korea 39. small country try
to go to korea for me small country guys
there you are 16. south korea number 16.
where yes pretty good that's it
see what see what's in power look at
them see what they are yeah let's see
what they are guarantee it's wrestling
there you men's ball
all right
hell yeah hold on dude hold on don't
all right we got this mean we got
men's marathon women's
i don't know
yeah we can't look it up but a lot of
it's wrestling this wrestling let's go
back and see how this works buy some
power lifting
what medals does south korea win does
north korea not compete
is it just yeah they do they do they
compete yeah i don't know if they did
this year but yeah things aren't
great for them
then show
it doesn't give you the specifics no
it's what it says for here mrs gold
metal target
yeah
four days ago so there's some judo in
there somewhere oh wait uh go to that
wikipedia south carolina
total
this one
no no no
scroll down chen
that wikipedia says south korea at the
olympics
i think that's just overall right but
it'd probably tell you what they got
like 20 20 uh you think scroll down 21
gold i think this is ever though oh it's
just that you might be able to scroll if
you scroll down though
okay that's 1980. uh taekwondo
taekwondo
judo 11 golds dude
11
archery judo 17. how good they are
holy [ __ ] ryan there's our there's our
weight lifting yeah 46 medals in judo 36
in wrestling look at how you're waiting
for three no dude hold on batman effects
you don't worry about that stuff we got
boxing 20. they're rough they're rough
dude they're good at argentina taekwondo
and weightlifting dude look 15 medals
football zero
hey 11 and wrestlers even in the
olympics no or they can't count that as
soccer i don't that was going on no
that's soccer soccer yeah they're not
yeah no not for them okay well
maybe i spoke a little too soon there
guys
they'll get there yeah
oh well all right all right what do you
got jim all right the first one was tito
ortiz versus anderson silva in a boxing
match for the oscar de la hoya fight uh
logan paul that's what i thought too hey
so this is for that same card with uh de
la hoya and vitor belfort i thought they
already had it like i had a date for him
i think anderson's definitely gonna win
that and i think belfor is going to
knock out oscar de la hoya
vader belfort was going to knock out
oscars
wow you seen him lately no
just jack oh you're talking about
detour's jack but oscars yes
i still think he can box his ass off huh
i don't think so if he's a hundred
percent people are saying if he's a
hundred percent he should i should he
should just dismantle yeah but he's not
he's probably clean
well yeah is is vitoria is going he's
going to be they're both going to be on
all this stuff okay they're going to be
on also detours jack when are they
training very dark yeah vitor's fast too
man oh yeah he was he's older now he's
still fast
and that's september 11th
september 11th that they're fighting
have you guys seen this in the news oh
my god yes so this dude who's a fan was
calling out at this mascot the mascot's
name is dinger so there's a black guy up
to back this this guy in the crowd kept
yelling dinger
dinger the dumbass social media goes
he's saying the n-word so there's like a
search for this guy and they're gonna
expel him from major league baseball and
they get the guy goes no i was yelling
dinger
and the rockies actually put this out
too that they're disgusted by the racial
slur without even looking into it
they they immediately put that out right
away right away so then they found out
that he's actually saying so it was
confirmed that he was saying yeah it's
100.
who he's talking to no like
he's not even looking at the guy oh
he's waving down like dinger's all the
way over here how crazy is that and they
wanted to expel this guy from major
league baseball and then the rocks cut
out a thing apologizing how did someone
catch that i don't know just look at
that i would have never even like after
a while you're like because people
because people are they're looking for
looking for it yeah because everybody
you get social points for getting rid of
racism look what i found everybody yeah
this has a baseball you're doing nice
guys in the
is there anything is there anything uh
more uncool than being racist do you
have you met anybody lately who's been
like down
like at a sporting event anywhere
there's probably yeah i've seen it
anywhere i i i was listening to two 75
year olds going they were talking about
this racist i don't have a they were
they were both from florida i don't have
any racist friends these two white white
people i was like even they were like
huh
it's [ __ ] hilarious
i get it
i mean it slightly sounds like it if
it's from a
yeah he's not looking at the players oh
you know what i got coming friday uh the
last of the cleveland indians with the
indian on the [ __ ] house
before they get rid of it
you think i'll get [ __ ] for wearing that
i don't think you should how'd you how
did you get it don't worry it's just a
collectible you don't wear hats it
doesn't mean and it doesn't mean you're
anti-native american no i'm super pro
logo of that indian it's my favorite
logo and you're native american
are you and i'm gonna take a gold pen
and put it in a gold tooth in it
you should as i did
when i did that 100 native american as i
did that when i was a kid
i took a gold sharpie put a gold tooth
in them wore it to school
talk of the day there you go we went to
we went to cherokee nation we went to
you know he and i and he fit right in
yeah i like and cherokees are giant
people too so he basically looks like
just like regular native american i know
but i did do my ancestry.com and there's
no native american none
none
yeah 10 percent italian what's up doug
only 10
yep uh oh 18 sorry 50 what was the
majority english english born and raised
what's up born arrested my mom born and
raised i just feel like you've got 50
and there's german scandinavian and then
uh 18 italian
have you done one of those for a dash of
african are you gonna be honest of
course i have i'm [ __ ] i'm like i mean
i'm 51
southern italian and the rest is
northwestern
peasant yeah a little iberian or
something no the majority said peasants
look at me peasants look at me
something's surprising here says
yeah yeah i'm the lord we've got all
this this is the lord
take a knee [ __ ]
no
all right
you didn't pay for that
what else you got
christian's got some
so
uh are you just picking the current
event i like that
i saw this over the weekend uh
fauci is under fire for reportedly uh
experimenting on dogs
he's facing uh he's spent four hundred
thousand dollars on research infest
infecting dogs with parasites but is
that part of his is that what they do
first of all he didn't the nih does he
okayed it
yeah it has to go through him but isn't
that what they do oh god you [ __ ] with
dogs people dog zone i've heard like
other what kind of dogs do we know
because there's certain dogs i'm okay
with it first of all i think
we have to we have to stop for a sec
guys so so the nih the national
institute of health
grants gives government grants to very
important research got it
fauci is a the head of nih
i i j this is going to come as a big
surprise everybody but he has a large
staff a large group of people
that delineate these different grants
based on a whole bunch of criteria okay
dogs suffer from from from parasites
sometimes to get the medicines that save
your dog's life and save your life they
do use animals in the last stage of
testing for medicines a lot of times are
have to be done on
animals because you are the next
case here this is political horseshit
it's just horseshit
it just is it's like i mean i'm not a
fan of jesus i'm not a fan of falci but
i want to be fair too yeah but it isn't
it isn't because his his
his team did operate on on dogs
right yeah the way they also did on
monkeys and on chimps it's nice
with hiv a lot of that study on hiv that
gave birth to these produce inhibitors
and stuff
that [ __ ] was done on [ __ ] chimps
because they're very close and it's
terrible research it sucks yeah they're
back in the 80s when i was going to
college there was a huge to do about
what they were doing to monkeys at the
nih
yeah man there's a lot of stuff and some
of it's not necessary some of it might
be but like
to take one study for so out of 20
billion dollars i think is the grants
they give four hundred thousand dollars
to some study somewhere about parasites
with dogs this is a this is fox news
horseshit yeah they're just trying to
throw something out there against
valencia
yeah they hate pouches so much yeah
this is this is like i'm so done with
cnn and fox news i'm so done with with
these opinion makers that are doing
whatever they can to discuss both sides
yeah
did your brother send you that article
oh no i just i actually just found it on
instagram and everything all right well
you're probably done with groon event
no i like read the whole entire thing
but like it's fox news yeah
you're not gonna like my next one yeah i
mean fox and tucker crosstalk though if
it was from the hill or somewhere like
in the middle then we could go with it
but foxy says
one agenda to destroy anybody especially
balchi which i don't like about you
right tucker carlson i wanted to be fair
with your criticism tucker carlson
literally said and then and
he went through the whole thing with
andrew cuomo and he said and he may be a
made member of the mafia
tucker carlson come on dude please like
i like what you say sometimes but when
you do that you just lose credibility
but we also don't need that like quote
we don't need it he's already fine we're
good you don't need to accuse them being
part of the mafia it's like i mean they
probably are but the thing is yeah is
you know the whole thing is like come on
dude
like some of this stuff between uh
that's where the media on both sides
right and left has lost my [ __ ] trust
well it's lost it's it's like the
public's trust correct so what do you
what do you watch i try to watch bbc i
try to watch i listen to npr it's tough
to find anything i have something to say
i take everything
i don't watch it either because of the
you know same reasons but it's just
like there's got to be something out
there at least that's like kind of look
there is in the middle or like give me
real facts yeah did just remember that
journalists are under enormous pressure
to stay relevant and get clicks and as
long as that's the case journalists are
more interested in the story that sells
which means
the
whatever who they destroy doesn't matter
it's being first and being loudest it's
not about being that's why i see so much
covid and delta yeah because that's what
people are going to tune into of course
and and they make money not off telling
you the truth they make money off your
attention you see where denzel broke
that down to that journal yeah i love it
yeah i love that i love that's why i
just said that because that's what i was
thinking about yeah right he said it's
it's not about truth it's not about who
you destroy it's about being first and
being loud
and and it was very very true and he's a
guy who knows you know he's been living
it because they did they tried to say
something about him
he was like like you know i i can't
remember exactly what this is recent um
maybe a couple years ago once once the
press decides you're a story you're done
yeah yeah yeah they're gonna go after
you yeah and he's not even out there
like in the media that crazy he kind of
just does his movies and just
journalists
literally
go to twitter to find stories if
somebody can say something about the
person and then try and value that's
what that's what you literally do that
and they do it all like nice anybody
have any ideas or stories and then they
get that and then they follow those
leads yeah and what happens is anybody
can say anything all they need all
journalists needs is that did you tell
somebody at the time do you have
somebody else who can corroborate your
story that you told them this afternoon
if it's factual and then so you you they
say yeah my friend will vouch for me
and then you know then you got a story
you got an article and i think that as
long as we have that the the media will
never gain we will always have a large
part of our country going i don't buy
this [ __ ] yeah look at the look at this
resistance to the vaccine it's a lot of
smart people just don't trust it they
don't know where to look because
nobody's communicating with them a lot
of people don't do maths work or don't
they work do lockdowns work it's too
confusing yeah all of this so we don't
know mm-hmm and so that's what happens
when people get help
yeah that's the problem yeah and she
goes and the media makes money off of
finding out this guy got a vaccine and
died this guy if i got a vaccine didn't
get a vaccine and died
you know
all right we'll move on from that topic
um this is for you brandon i don't know
if you know this but a e is having a
three-part series on serial killers and
it starts uh oh you are aware the
problem is i'm sure i've seen all the
footage they're gonna use oh
like there's nothing new it's kind of
like shark week i've seen the same great
white jump out of the water and eat that
fake seal every year
serial killers i've seen
so unless you have some new [ __ ] i mean
i'm still going to watch it but yeah
and it's all the it's all the big ones
heavy hitters and the ones that got away
they explained how they got away for so
long yeah that's what this is the book
to read did you read the murder room
that's the best book i've ever read on
the psychology of cereal no no way no
richard walter john douglas by far well
richard walter was the guy who came up
with the double helix for the idea of
how a serial killer comes about but he
would he would say stuff like this he'd
look at a crime scene i guess this guy
was killing women by a river it was like
the green river guy and he said he said
uh you'll find him um put cars in the
area and you'll find him because they
come back to it probably masturbating in
his car and they they caught the guy no
wow
for any circular stuff you gotta do john
douglas cause they did the show um
what's the [ __ ] show you told me
about that you told me about that wow
it's one of my favorite [ __ ] shows
but johnny douglas mine hunter so the
the mine hunter the series
three seasons i think now two seasons
the the the characters written off him
and his books what are true stories
he keyed the came up with the term
serial killer he came up the serial
killer division in the fbi like it's all
his doings and he did it by so charles
manson ted bundy uh
all the main guys he would go interview
and he'd find similarities in all of it
and then he put together a profile how
you find out a serial killer and in the
murder room richard walter um i think
that's his name was giving a teaching to
the fbi about you know the kind of
mentality of a serial killer and as he's
giving all the talks cereal came in yeah
and they and they he was a suspect in
one of the things and they got him they
said you gotta get out of here but they
didn't have evidence to put him on there
and say why would he come in and he goes
what do you mean because why would he
come in he goes because everybody wants
to know about themselves he doesn't know
why he has these urges these insane
urges yeah they are there and and it's
sexual it's like you get off
they go back to the where the murder
sites when they jack off and stuff or
they take like a memento like a earring
or something and store it because then
they pick it up and they rub it so it
reminds them of what they did to the
victim it's solved but but but like that
whole circle thing like how they got
away for so long a lot of it was just
bad
cops like not mean like they're bad like
they're stupid they didn't know how to
trace the precincts didn't talk so the
reason why the nightstart got away with
it in so many like san bernino and
burbank and in the valley because the
the the division is never going to talk
to each other no so one would like to do
we have this guy who killed this bird
they want to help each other out so he
got away from what the caller ever
forever until finally
uh
one of the douglas another cop was like
hold on i saw in the news that the exact
same thing happened in burbank that's
happened to our thing so he'd call over
there and even then they were like no
we're good amazing no we got to work
together man because we're gonna be able
to find a pattern here then they went to
all the other different cities and found
the pattern
think about how dark that [ __ ] is though
like think about whether the golden
stalker would take your eyes out
like i'm gonna kill this couple and then
remove their eyes well and then he would
rape a mama from the kid i mean terrible
he's the worst of the worst dude you'd
raise smell the mom in front of the kid
which is the one that uh
pat and oswald
uh does the golden state kill her that's
the golden [ __ ] and she caught him
through the uh through dna through
ancestry.com dude he was he was why did
he make a woman he make the woman have
the couple the woman had the fat the guy
would have to lie down he put a tea cup
with like he'd put a t-shirt on his body
killer no no this is uh this is the
golden state yeah he put a t t set so t
cup on his body and then he goes now i'm
gonna i'm gonna have sex with your wife
if you if i hear that teacup rattle if
you move i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
that's how [ __ ] up this guy was and he
just got off on making people do that
but but a lot of it like that the golden
state killer the night stalker you
couldn't get away with it now because
there's cameras everywhere people are
aware they sleep with their door shuts
their windows shut their security alarms
like the nightstar got away like he was
killing the summer because people slept
with their windows open he would get in
the house through the windows yeah you
were pointing that out when we were in
tacos
well he's gonna [ __ ] not everyone has
dogs
when would tacoma i said dude if i was
serial killer i'd come to tacoma there's
no ac everyone has their windows open
everybody yeah and i literally i said
that out loud everyone's all what the
[ __ ] i'm like i'm just saying
this is a place are you a deep sleeper
oh yeah yeah oh no no i'm no no no none
since i have kids no my son will move
and i'll be up yeah man i hear a bump in
the night i'm i'm up for the rest of the
night yeah man and that i got that's why
you got to have dogs but
you know what three error 15.
i don't i wouldn't didn't get a cause my
buddy said that his jerry mcfadden my
buddy he said
jerry they would they would always try
to catch him sleeping they would always
try and he'd be sleeping and they the
other football players would come in and
they'd sneak in super quiet sometimes
they'd just look good
and they would just they just they were
just like
creak the door opener just like look in
the window and they'd just hear this
hey
[Laughter]
how do you know
and i said to my how come you never he
goes because i never know who's going to
[ __ ] come in with it
when i was a kid i remember uh we used
to wake my dad up and he'd get so
startled like he was in vietnam he never
served him he was in the military never
vietnam right like what the [ __ ] is your
problem dude we'd like
like hit us like oh my god so he's like
waking up with a [ __ ] broomstick yeah
but then i wake up like that now do you
have my girls like you never served in
[ __ ] nom when you wake up did you
ever have like uh did you ever when you
played football did were there certain
dudes on the team that you would just
never [ __ ] with i feel like that guy
lawrence vickers was just such a [ __ ]
badass like that kind of guy who like if
you came into his house even if he was
asleep you'd be a [ __ ] dead man you
showed me the professional football
player yeah yeah no i mean why'd someone
break in this house no i'm saying
there's certain guys like my buddy jerry
he was a giant dude but he just had this
[ __ ] weird
this this
like there were these cops and they had
this police dog
and he's staring at the dog like this
and
my buddy goes why are you looking at a
dog and he goes i don't know
i killed that dog what and he goes what
he goes everybody's letters they let
that dog loose on me i'm just looking at
how i would kill him and he goes well
what would you do and he goes i think i
grab his front paws and i just pull him
over
and he that's how he was always thinking
a little loose i mean
what happened some dudes are like that i
feel like tim kennedy's like that
certain dudes are just always like the
[ __ ] i wonder if i could you know but
this guy was just they're always he was
always ready he's always ready just
always [ __ ] ready
always some people are like that but
those serial killers they they they
they
go and view the place out so it's they
see a big guy they just move on to the
next house
they're not going to they case the
houses before you of course they don't
like deny stalker would drive around
like he would want to murder that night
but there just wasn't a great
opportunity so he would wait weeks for
the perfect interesting so it would be a
dark house bigger dude they were like
nah no if there's that more than one guy
he'd be like nope and he would and the
nightstalker you case place then he'd
always come back and he'd always kill
the husband first because they put up
the biggest struggle yeah so he'd shoot
the husband before they could even wake
up he'd shoot him right in the temple
and then he would attack the kid and
wife he said he's doing [ __ ] well would
you watch that got did you watch the
documentary on netflix and nightstalker
yeah yeah it was so good the book's
better way better what book what's going
to keep you up the night stalker book
keep you up keep you up poor dude he was
the worst i don't know why he didn't get
more publicity the worse dude i can't i
can't that btk killer's [ __ ] buying
torch or kill terrible dudes yeah
horrifying you'd like the um true crime
podcast because they talk about all that
[ __ ]
i'm trying to think of if i've heard it
yeah somebody i don't like it i get it
when
have you heard of them the cheshire
murders yes yeah that's [ __ ] up some
dark stuff yeah yeah i can't yeah i was
a high-gained wife that was awesome yeah
and artists too yeah yeah the husband
still survived my friend went to the
cheshire academy they had him speak at
the graduation
they have them do it every year stuff's
so dark man yeah i don't like that yeah
there's darkness hard pass for me
yeah
all right check this out uh you probably
saw this brennan but no i haven't oh the
podcast that the where whack 100 was on
and he interviewed six nine i guess six
and i reenacted a gunshot sound and they
just laughed at
[Laughter]
how fascinating is it it's fascinating
but it's kind of tough to watch because
he just takashi just yells so much to
where you're like dude just just sit and
have the conversation and just listen
like it's just he might be on a lot of
medications he's a very passionate yeah
he's i think he's young and he has like
a lot to say yeah so he's like very like
he's not in control he doesn't listen
well yeah
it'd be interesting to see if he if i
hope you know hopefully survives but if
he if he when he's 50 what he's going to
be like it's with all those face tattoos
yeah and also like when what what
happens to to a young man when he calms
down and the fire stops and the damage
that'd be a fast one
have you seen the documentary on him
that showtime did i didn't it like
you'll just
i think you'll remember we watched
you do okay because he's just like he's
just a kid that he's a kid more guys
but he's also a guy who
you know
his success wasn't by accident like
everything was calculated like all the
trolling his crazy hair
everything his marketing everything was
calculating like he's pretty [ __ ]
brilliant with that stuff yeah now
you're gonna do that and you can get
attention that you don't want but you're
still going to sell jagillian records
but when you watch it and you know his
dad give him up for you know his dad
dipping out on him well there you go
he's making a name for himself and like
what i see is what you see like he's a
mezzies this mexican kid in this
you know in the su in the the the bronx
or where the [ __ ] he's from and he found
he figured it out when nobody else could
he figured out and you're like yeah
like i know i know he's like he's
probably the kind of guy that would have
been successful like if he had come up
with a loving family and stuff he would
have found no i don't know i don't think
i don't think so you think the damage or
the damage the damage yeah
like you know there's certain comics
like oh
you're like this because you have this
chip on your shoulder and the damage or
there's certain athletes where it's like
oh that chip on your shoulders fighters
like it's like they have to come from
those rotten places to become brilliant
tyson for takashi it's like he came from
you know that weird atmosphere
desperation
but you like they have the tattoo artist
and the lady who'd come in and he would
come in and before he was [ __ ] didn't
have money like hey do my hair rainbow
she's like what you're like no i'm
telling it's gonna be sick everyone's
been copying it she's like you're out of
your mind just do it and she would do it
and she's like sure enough a year later
the kid's famous as [ __ ] yeah he's just
he would say like i'm telling you i'm
going places
he blew up pretty quick fast fast super
fast and i i don't know how it ends for
him i hope he doesn't die at all i think
that'd be tragic as [ __ ] yeah but
yeah because there's this there's
something to a story when you watch the
documentary
of course of course i'm sure i would
have compassion i don't know if i would
be his best friend but you know
you're like um yeah the guy did
something right i feel like it's just a
shame how tall it's a guy like that who
realized probably early on that nobody
gave a [ __ ] about him that he was truly
on his own and that it was up to only
him to save his own life and he came you
know right and he has demons he's
dealing with he probably needs
extensive therapy sure yeah i mean how
is it and he's always
but just him talking like when the guy
goes that gangster whack 100 goes
you know as a man to take care of your
family's like yeah he's like well you
have that one baby he's like well i
don't know if it's mine he's like well
how do you why don't you just take a dna
test and find out is it because it's not
mine he's like we'll just you can
eliminate all that just take it have you
and the mom going for a dna test we can
find if that child's yours so you have
to deal with he's like yeah that's a
good point he's like but i only nutted
her once and then he's like well it
doesn't work like that takashi like
that's how you could tell he's something
yeah this was the blood recently yeah
he's like he doesn't
pregnancy doesn't work that way yeah he
goes my man one time it could happen
he's like nah i was only once you're
like oh my god see it's almost like you
wanted that guy just you want that guy
to kind of be around takashi to kind of
guide him
he has good people in his life that's
the other thing no 100 i think it's
pretty it was pretty interesting to
watch like him with him being so young
this black 100 guy being in his 50s and
like really coming from that life and
for the takashi to try to explain to him
how things are and it's like
i mean this i mean this guy's like the
bread and butter you know you get some
of these these i mean rappers or
anything like that kind of i'm not
saying i don't
i don't know too much about takashi but
like people that glorify
the street life right like the people
that didn't really come from it yeah
they weren't really bred in it yeah but
but they see and they're like damn that
that looks cool you know they want to
feel like they both they can belong it's
like it's like surprising never having
to overcome yeah so people who are
really from the street are trying
they're not they're trying to
they said that i think stanley crowd
said that about the musicians the white
musicians of the 70s they their heroes
were all the great blues black blues
musicians and the jurassic musicians and
like james brown and [ __ ] and and and if
you look at a lot of the great jazz
musicians are like you know billie
holiday and charlie parker they all had
heroin problems and stuff and he said
those people were
were trying to overcome something like
survivor guild being second-class
citizens and the drugs came with the
dulling the pain of all the [ __ ] and
then and he said then you had like a
bunch of english kind of you know
kids and american kids like jim morrison
and janice joplin who just wanted to be
like that so what they do they started
doing drugs too because their heroes did
drugs yeah but it's that's a little bit
more like subscribing something instead
of trying to overcome something there's
a big difference man yeah you know one
is you're assuming a costume and a
character and the other is you're trying
to get rid of that [ __ ] costume and
character you're trying to be just
trying to live you're trying to survive
that's crazy
it is interesting because like like you
said like yeah i don't come from that
world either so it's like interesting to
like hear about it and listen to people
like talking i mean my dad my dad tells
me you know all his stories and stuff
but it is pretty it's just
if you were if you were miles davis or
you were a great musician back in the
50s 60s and you know you would have to
come 40 50 60s you
you would perform for a white crowd and
make money but you and your band had to
come through this the servant's entrance
you had to code through the kitchen
is that weird [ __ ] like that that you
don't think about where you're like oh
[ __ ] man i gotta go i can't go through
here because that's not for colored
people i gotta go around
yeah it's like that down some of these
comedy clothes we walk through the
kitchen
right oh that's true what else
[Laughter]
this is a pretty insane story
so this guy right here hold on not that
oh god that one's great though this guy
right here
uh his sister was raped by the uh
another person right an older guy and
then this guy was in jail because he
stabbed someone and he also did a
joyride and then accidentally hit the
trooper as well so he's in jail for a
certain time didn't say how long but
then that his sister's rapist was put in
the same cell as him oh they didn't know
no well he's saying that they knew he's
saying that they knew but they said they
didn't know so he said he wanted to be
get get out of the cell because he knows
he's gonna do something bad but they
didn't they didn't like you know let him
get out so he ended up killing him
stomping his head beating the crap out
of him so now he's in jail for another
24 something years wow
that's on the jail and that yeah and
that guy also good for him he was
arrested for other sex crimes against
kids too so
uh there you go good yeah because that
guy those this is
to do that did the kill yeah beat up the
dude
those guys get killed anyway oh
take him to [ __ ] scopa yeah wally's
wow yeah have a meal with him at wally
somebody goes for you yeah
that's [ __ ] how do you go you feel
like that they should cut down a
sentencing i would say 24 years yeah i
agree with the terrible human being
also though by the way you put him in
the [ __ ] you put him in as a cellmate
what did you expect that's the guy he
killed oh wow
oh cool a white walker and then
he got he got some hits in it
and then i think i read somewhere too
that there's uh a petition out there for
him too to help him out yeah i mean at
least communications the government
doesn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] petition
but yeah i hear you he they should
celebrate that man
yeah i mean i i raped his sister [ __ ]
you yeah what do you expect when she was
she's still a minor to this day oh yeah
yeah oh what are you expecting to do
when i would [ __ ] kill that yeah well
yeah what do you do yeah what do you
think he's going to you can't that's
that's the there's got to be a uh there
should be an insanity plea there i lost
my mind you know [ __ ] that he did say he
was out of his head in prison dude
that's on the prison that's on the
prison didn't the guy brag about the
[ __ ] he would do oh that's that's a good
point too so he was that's what he's
saying this guy the the guy that had the
sister he's saying the guy was trying to
explain to him all the things he did to
his sister
and he didn't know that was his no he
knew they found out
dude i was like what the [ __ ] you're
talking out of the blue you sent me to
the same institution the same unit the
same pod uh in the same cell as the dude
that locked up that got locked up
because what he did in my little sis
um he scribed hitting the jackpot and
casino stuff time goes started however
that he tried to get himself out of the
situation by telling the guards but he's
dismissed
um
when munger told him details about the
abuse hell no
hell no
i mean come on man yeah you can't
[ __ ] blame a man there's no there's
no way do that if you didn't kill him
so
so he was on suicide watch do you think
he may have told the guy all that
details to get that guy to kill him
that's an interesting point but also i
think that guards i i think the guards
put him in there because they wanted him
to kill him i think that was the other
thing
i mean what's the chance of that 100 the
guy that raped your little sister they
know they know what yeah
and then he tells them like dude this
guy right my fish get me out of i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this guy and you
don't do anything yeah they did that and
then then they're not gonna take any
responsibility i guarantee then you put
all the blame on the guy this is gonna
be i guarantee this this is gonna be
somehow overturned or at least there's
some [ __ ] going on that's [ __ ] yeah
still serves like for at least five to
seven years all right all right all
right
all
right
all
right
all
right
all right all right all right
didn't you say his original sentence it
said he stabbed someone and then took a
joyride on a trooper's car and then
accidentally or injured his
25 years for that i mean he may have a
long rap sheet but either yeah he'll
come out either way he did the lord's
work god was like dude i get it did the
lord's work
i was like i get it
dude raped a minor you deserve to
[ __ ] die dude we have a friend who
told us a story about a
child molester who got his head cut off
uh right right next to his cell and woke
up the next day and he was like i smell
pennies
well it was blood i don't know smell the
iron in the blood you know
you didn't know that story just heard he
just heard uh this guy was spanish and
he was a child molester and then he
heard like spanish speaking and kind of
some shuffling no screaming or anything
well woke up the next morning he was
like that's weird woke up the next
morning and they cut his head off he was
a child molester yeah they don't play
that show
a buddy i know uh he he was
back back in the day he and a bunch of
inmates would have a game whoever beat
the [ __ ] out of the most pedophiles by
the end of the week would win a jackpot
of like cigarettes and thomas yeah i
would donate they would pour like rat
poison in their bed so yeah yeah he was
like a real that's what you get yeah
you touch kids well now they put them in
separate they have separate they protect
yeah they [ __ ] protect them which
they shouldn't
let the boys take care of them
but then you get 25 years so i don't
know all right what else you got you all
right on a lighter note this is all the
[ __ ] thanks is that so funny there's a
psa someone said something i was like
okay here we go
that's
so um just checking in look i've been
kind of on the fence about this for a
while that's why i've never spoke on it
but with the amount of people that i
know recently that have gotten covered
and with like the numbers rising i think
it's important for me to say like
i got the vaccine
i
think everybody should i think it's
really important like that we all do
this just as like citizens as americans
we have to look out for each other and
get the [ __ ] under control guys so like
i suggest to all my followers you guys
make set an appointment and get the
vaccine first things psych
[ __ ]
don't fix it i never had covered you
sticking me with that [ __ ]
needle it's the [ __ ] flu
the game
okay if you're sick stay inside i'm
trying if i'm gonna okay why are we
working around y'all if y'all
if you're in danger stay your ass inside
i'll tie your way to [ __ ] man
he posted something again oh my god i
love him
it says that
i woke up and chose chaos
real simple okay
just like you have the right
to be mad at me because i said i'm not
going to get the vaccine that oh i can't
believe he sat down
just like you have the right to be mad
i have the right to not get that [ __ ]
you know i wanted to but my immune
system said it's good okay it doesn't
need to be tampered with okay it said
it's good okay
let's be real
99 of you [ __ ]
wouldn't use a shampoo that's not fda
approved but you're willing to get some
experimental government injection okay
there's more evidence for ufos being
real than that uh vaccine being healthy
for you well that's not terribly
scientific
but if you ought to come get me let's
get the [ __ ] out of here or am i getting
my vaccine papers
the problem is that it's not very
scientific right like he's
he
don't take that advice
if you look at the metadata it does i
mean i look like
it's okay brian i've seen your hair back
no but it does it if you look just look
at the massive the my almost says just
look at the if you really look at the
data like the overall data
this is a little it's chet
uh this is from cat i guess this is
going viral now this guy it's apparently
the black version of john cena i don't
know if i can see it can you guys see it
a little bit
i could see a little bit yeah but not
handsome no i wouldn't say holy [ __ ]
handsome guy i wouldn't see him on the
stream like oh that's [ __ ] i think he
looks a little bit more like a young
floyd mayweather not right there
actually i don't think so right there i
think that's just i think maybe their
noses and lips
they put them actually together
all right yeah the nose and lip pretty
similar uh-huh
is that a real picture were there
together there no
they just superimpose them then you just
put them next together
yeah i mean i don't really see that much
but i see a little bit of a result a
little bit
big fella
very big fella
um
there's another one cat
nfl is enforcing taunting penalties so
if you do more than twice or something
like that you get
in trouble what are they labeled that's
the thing it didn't really say but it is
when it's when you like you know
you say bad things to them if you if you
get like a touchdown or whatever all
that kind of crap to your you know your
opponents i don't know much about
taunting another nfl [ __ ] keep scrolling
down
uh yeah i don't who gives a [ __ ] c2
violations results in automatic ejection
with fines and even suspension dicey
stuff where you know they're trying to
make the game kind of boring it's so
weird but uh
but the you know they launched the new
hard knock season with the cowboys it's
fantastic oh nice it is yeah it's
fantastic i love that [ __ ] what why am i
sucking
in the past 10 years they've changed a
lot of rules right like so you can't
spear with your hit too hard yeah yeah
do you agree with that as a football
player no no
no
the guys get thrown out of the games for
like if they hit a guy who's not looking
and [ __ ] it's just that they used to be
able to make the game when you played it
if you tackle a quarterback below the
knees you get flagged like it's just wow
it's not good man
but is that to keep people from being
injured as much that's to protect the
most valuable yeah assets on the field
which is the quarterback they call the
tom brady rule oh
tom brady played a lot of his career
when those rules were in place do you
think if he had played the when those
rules were not in place he would have
lasted as long oh yeah yeah but he's
fine
they're just kind of pussifying them
right
yeah i wonder if it had an effect on
injuries
like you know what i mean i wonder if it
actually makes a difference or is it
just and people get around it it's weird
what about the head one
the the
you were never really allowed to spear
were you with your head spear not really
yeah
but now if you if you use your head to
tackle you you know
ronnie lot did that a lot ronnie used to
knock himself out yeah
you're trying you're trying to make a
dangerous game safe
you know
yeah it's a dangerous game a little bit
like boxing you know what you're getting
into it just comes with the territory
yeah yeah
i just got you all right well real quick
it's abusive threatening or insulting
language or gestures towards other
players coaches etc sticky subject man
is now suing paramount johnny knoxville
and this is a tragic story because the
shame is is bam margaret is one of the
originals yeah so he's suing one of his
the reasons why assuming he says they
took his ideas as well he wrote a lot of
the skits they're leaving that here
they told bam we'll have you in on the
new
movie if you're clean dude we're trying
to make because you're an addict you got
to be clean in order to be part of this
movie he failed the drug test i think
for adderall but i'm sure he's doing a
lot of this [ __ ] so when he failed the
drug test he went all right dude you
gotta get clean otherwise they thought
by threatening them like you're not
being part of the movie unless you get
clean that would be the rock bottom that
get them clean wasn't it a contract yes
yeah yeah yeah so by him not obeying by
the contract it voids so he can't be
part of the movie this isn't the other
guys in jackass like johnny knoxville
and stevo trying to just [ __ ] him over
this is them looking out for their
friends saying dude you got to be clean
yeah to be on jacket sure which i
totally agree with but it's like yeah
why would they want to [ __ ] him over now
like why now
the one thing he has in this lawsuit
though that is interesting is it says
that the they made him take medications
like they had he said part of the
contract was he had to take these
medications that it made him depressed
and gain anxiety so if they made him
take medication medications out that
would be the one i'll be like
taking
it's because like when it takes you away
from the drug of your choice
you get depressed yeah and also some
medications make you depressed yeah and
give you anxiety or anxiety an addict
will
do a lot of yeah the attic is gonna find
its way around what to to protect their
identity
it's all a [ __ ] show it sucks yeah it
does suck yeah it's also have you have
you seen the uh trailer for the new
jackass i haven't seen it like 50
getting attacked by sharks and stuff and
then still like games
all right
it's still going to kick castle i'm sure
i'll watch it i love it but it's still
like getting a little old for this yeah
knoxville must love payne or something
it's incredible he's 50 now i mean
johnny knoxville is the raddest
[ __ ] you want to talk about he
got hit with that bulldog he's such a
badass like i'm sorry like that's he's
he's doing a new movie i think on
paramount he's pretty special in a lot
of ways he's pretty cool i loved him in
that one movie with the rock um
walking tall yeah or whatever he is that
was that's what he was willing to do
he's good yeah bad grandpa he's great
duke of hazards yeah ringer turtles
isn't he in yeah yeah
the ringer he's good yeah
he couldn't make that movie today no
he pretended to be have like mental
illness so he'd be in the special
olympics to finish first and bet on
himself because like someone like a
mafia he owed a mafia money or something
weird like that and he was trying to
make money great movie though didn't he
tape himself to a billboard for a
publicity sunday night
and that was for chamois look at there's
johnny nick smoking flip with that boy
like that's so crazy that's the new
character blindfolded smoking and he
just let himself get okay this is the
trailer
look at his face
dude that's really scary man that's
insane
i remember when they had that king cobra
and that he was he was like [ __ ]
terrified that can't go but it was no
show oh god i think i'll bite you right
in your [ __ ] yeah some about those
guys getting together just brings back
that's great lovable yeah yeah very
nostalgic
but man oh man
what else you got jen crazy that's
pretty much it yeah that was great shout
out to jackass shout out to the boys
all right kids well uh next week rally
north carolina
next thursday friday saturday north
carolina august 19th 21st that is rally
uh improv right yeah yeah rally north
carolina is next week then august 26-28
shows almost sold out la jolla
california la jolla economy store right
outside san diego california san jose
california september 9th through the
11th san antonio texas september 24th
one show september 25th one show then
denver colorado september 30th through
october 2nd tickets at fatkz.com
i'll see you houston houston next week
august 19th through the 21st get your
tickets i'm bringing heat whole new hour
buffalo new york helium september 9-11
denver colorado comedy works september
23rd 25th chicago illinois improv
september 30th august 1st and columbus
ohio funny bone august 8th through 9th
october 8th 39th october 8th october
sorry i mean it's okay all right august
26th brea improv oh did it not update oh
well september yeah will you refresh it
should be what's wrong with it
i have another date uh uh september 8th
cobb's comedy club and then i'm meeting
up with brendan at uh san jose improv
and then october 7th through the 9th
i'll be at tampa florida side splitters
october 8th uh sorry 28th through the
30th i'll be in washington dc at the dc
comedy law and then november 17th uh
tacoma comedy club november 18th spokane
comedy club you're giving dates all the
way to november doug oh i mean
he kept scrolling hey
man right kids that's it love you see ya